feminism allowed women to be bailed out
of every single bad decision that we
make ever like if we want to if we want
to sleep around there's birth control
yeah if that doesn't work we have
abortion if that doesn't work you can
get um government assistance for being a
single mother
um if that doesn't work
um you can you know marry someone it
could be the father of your kid could
not
um and then you know leave him and take
half yeah
[Laughter]
I did not get a penny yeah
and then and then on top of that like
um
I mean men you know commit like suicide
a lot of times after these divorces a
lot of times like women make bad
decisions at the expensive man it also
allows us if we want to be homeless
there's women's shelters too like